take two today report to the results of
its first fiscal of 2017 which ended on
june thirtieth 2016 thanks to grand
theft auto 5 and GTA online it was
relatively successful quarter for the
company though it still experienced the
loss I'm Dave and welcome to York please
just give us red dead redemption two
already GS news update CAAP net revenue
is on the rise during the quarter grown
thirteen percent of three hundred and
eleven point six million dollars
compared to the 270 5.3 million dollars
during the same period last year take to
identify GTA 5 GTA online NBA 2k16 and
battle born as its main contributors all
0 CEO Strauss Zelnick noted in a
conference call with investors that
battleborn did not perform as well as
expected digital net revenue is also up
for the quarter from 154 million last
year to 170 2.1 million dollars this
year similarly what take two calls
recurrent consumer spending things like
DLC and virtual currency was up eighteen
percent year-over-year accounting for
thirty-one percent the company's total
net revenue take to know to the GTA
online had record bookings but didn't
specify exactly how much money it
generated as private earnings take two
also reveal the console versions of XCOM
2 had been delayed slightly they were
now launched on sep tember 27th in north
america and sep tember 30th
internationally it also touched on
rockstars next projects albeit as begley
as it possibly could it stated Rockstar
Games is also hard at work on some
exciting future projects that will be
revealed soon so what would you like to
see from Rockstar next now's know in the
comments section below or find me on
Twitter at a regular Dave and for
everything GTA make sure you stay tuned
to gamespot com
you